who are these seven and a half million migrants living in Australia
the English are still the largest migrant group by far within Australia
for a long time
the kiwis new zealanders were the second largest migrant group in Australia
that changed seven years ago
by now kiwis are only the fourth largest group of migraines in Australia
for a long time
it looked like the Chinese were going to be the biggest mi group in Australia
but even before the pandemic the indian started to overtake the Chinese
essentially the Chinese government wanted to show Australia whose Boston
they would held visas for a little bit
and now of course big parts of China and lockdown
and people can't actually leave the country
and these are our four largest micro groups in Australia